That's not true. She's been an amazing person ever since I was a kid
. I've seen her several times as a member of the Meat Group
.
If I'm okay, I'm on a different level, and
I'm a mild-mannered person because I overlap myself with Hina dolls.
That's why I really respect that kind of
thing.8 Ah, I think I'll take a look at Ajon.
It's not like we were on bad
terms, but Mr. Mito, who was defeated in Shokugeki, I unilaterally cut him off
.  -
If there's anything I can do, tell me anything I can answer
Don't worry about that, just borrow
it I'm happy that Nakiri-san and I have the same favorite things
ana
[music]
What's
going on?
If you don't mind, why don't you come with me
?  I didn't even try to see it, it
was such a beautiful city
here